[Music]
hello everybody my name is Vitaly namer
I am the Grand Master resident for the
next 30 days I would like to thank the
this Center is chess club for hosting me
I'm very excited yes last time I was a
grandmaster resident for three weeks
this time is a month hopefully next time
is gonna be even more but I guess they
like me so I am very excited to come
back and coach them chess and welcome
welcome to our strategy class
so today we are going to discuss some
strategical nuances so today the lesson
is going to be about unusual exchanges
well there are lots of unusual things in
chess in general but today we are going
to discuss about unusual exchanges
unusual moves that we typically don't do
in the chess games and this is why it's
so much difficult for us to make it in
our games so this is not going to be our
neck our first position this is from a
game that was played between Gregorian
and Capri cheek and then 1975 in this
position it is white to move so why to
move and make the best move so I'm going
to give you the views at home - if you
need to pause the video and think about
this the next move that white has done
but yeah so I why to move and I'm also
going to give a few minutes to audience
in the chest up to think about
okay Bishop f3 anybody has any other
suggestions okay Queenie for very good
both are good moves moving forward
that's always a good good sign
okay okay well looks like Queen a4 and
Bishop f3 all candidate pose
maybe we can obviously play some other
moves like h3 which which which might
help us in this position so first of all
what we do when we get a puzzle or a
position we like to do an assessment of
the position that's a step that
sometimes people forget to do so how do
we how do we assess the position
basically we need to figure out who is
better in this position number one what
you would like to do is to count the
material balance so as you can see in
this position both sides of two bishops
we have two rooks queen and each side
has six points so materials material is
speaking we have equal position then we
have to look at some of the positional
nuances for example we look at King
safety in this moment both of the Kings
are pretty safe because well we know
that the Kings in behind those three
pawns over here this this King is also
pretty safe is not exposed anywhere then
what what we would like to see is to
compare is the pawn structure as you can
see from this position white has what we
call three islands at three pawn
Shayne's
black has only two point chains
the last point chains we have the better
for us okay now why is that because the
last point we stop the chess game with
just one pawn chain perfect pawn chain
going from a7 to
each survey of this knife nice eight
points defending each other now the more
and more punches we get for example if
you look at whites position those those
are points the eighty point is
technically is an isolated pawn which
means that he has no friends next to him
you know those those those guys are
gonna back him up so you know that that
makes the pawns are much weaker so in
this case white is going to be the one
I'm sorry black is going to be the one
who the better point shape because
there's only two versus three pawn
chains so this test upon chains but then
we can go each piece by piece and
compare the pieces now for example we
can start with the bishops white bishops
versus black bishops now obviously white
bishop this Bishop on h4 is kind of
attacking this pawn so he is doing
something the bishop on e2 not doing
much right now he's just covering the
derrick on e tool on the other hand the
black has this nice French netted bishop
on g7 which attacks the backwards d4
pawn so that's that he's doing a pretty
good job this Bishop on on d5 is also
beautiful beautifully placed he is
blocking blockading the the pawn on d4
he is also attacking g2 en sometimes
it's also useful to defend your own
points if you can see from this position
this bishop on d5 is very difficult to
move as well it's very difficult for
white to to make any progress basically
those pawns that he has on c5 and d4
those are fixed points those ones are
very difficult to move because they're
blockaded usually the best blockading
piece is the knight but yes but we don't
have the Knights here so
at least we got we gather our bishops
over there so just for the moment let's
assume that blacks that blacks bishops
are better if you can see the Queen's
probably White's Queen is going to be
look look going to look for us a bit
better because maybe it's positioned
slightly on the second rank instead of
the last rank of the queer they
comparing to the black Queen however you
know white screen is not attacking
anybody and she's just defending now
black screen black screen on the other
hand she has some potential threat over
the D file attacking the de-spawn before
again so the problem is this pawn on d4
again now rooks though definitely white
is better
right so white is better blacks blacks
rooks are this guy is defending is you
know blocked this guy is blocked and our
rooks although they are also blocked at
the moment but this is just temporary
because we know and you know they in the
center so this is kind of the idea okay
so we kind of made the assessment and I
think what we got from this position is
that it's pretty much pretty much
balanced we have our white assist
weaknesses or with the pawn chain but he
has a little bit more space is real so
bit better black bishop so it's kind of
a fight it's a very interesting fight
the next few moves will probably decide
who will get the advantage who will get
the upper hand so the the two moves that
were considered by the audience here the
Chess Club where Queen f4 and Bishop f3
so let's let's up with this move Queen
f4 Queen fo is a very good move it moves
it moves the Queen forward it attacks f7
although it's still defended but and it
also you know defends the bishop on on
h4m Orion forces it and obviously opens
up the rook the problem with the queen
of four is probably it's the it's
nothing concrete so for example if you
would
b-black how would you how would you
respond here with it with black what
would be the plan here for black yes
please okay interesting idea so to push
to put to play f6 with the idea of g5
hmm interesting what do you guys think
about this plan is it good not so good
right the promise is first of all I
don't like it because it exposes this
diagonal again not at this moment it
might not be neither not not might not
be weak at the moment but it might
become if we exchange the bishops at
some point but the the most the most
thing that bothers me is that f6 who
really blocks out bishop on g7 and
probably white is going to see that and
maybe move his Bishop to g3 and we will
have to figure out how to all via C we
can push a5 then but again this diagonal
might be exposed so a good idea but
maybe not necessarily what we need to do
at the moment
Wow very good very good explanation
actually so you know guys in a there's a
thought process in chess so once we
assess the position we're trying to come
up with those candidate moves we found
them so how did we find them so one of
the steps in chess is to ask yourself
the question how what is my worst piece
and how can I improve this so I can
either try to improve one of my pieces
although really I don't see a way so
this so there is this there's this move
Bishop after I can improve the bishop
and the rook or there is another
question I can ask myself what is my
opponent's best piece and how can I
exchange it so it's all very relative
and I like the fact that yeah you guys
all agree that the d5 bishop is very
annoying so however against Queen of
four so let's see let's see how can I
okay maybe I can play okay what is the
worst peaceful black probably district
on the a8 and we know that the rocket
will probably go to d8 in order to help
the attack on the default pawn so I
would say probably maybe Queen d7 would
be it would be an interesting move for
for black and then if Bishop f3 well I'm
kind of debating between immediately
playing rule d8 or maybe I have to play
something like e six not so not to not
to we can not to lose my a seven point
so one of one of those moves now if it
takes you can probably take with a queen
and although this Bishop is kind of
annoying but I succeeded in stopping the
blockade so that's a good idea
but surprisingly the correct move is
actually Bishop to f3
I'm going to give a double exclaim very
very unnatural move for for us to make
Bishop f3 ok let's look at blacks
options I mean what what can what can
black do again if I try to play Queen d7
then black and probably take on d5 and
would lose the pawn here only 7 so for
example this take take a bishop takes
only 7
right so so one of those I would
probably prefer to play take it with the
bishop but with the rook it's all so
simple it's pretty good okay so Bishop
to f3 so we are all in in the agreement
that black and needs to take on F T so
this is how the game went Bishop f3 and
pawn takes on f3 okay so yeah I mean we
learn from you know when since well kids
that we should not expose a king but in
this in this in this situation first of
all black doesn't have any pieces near
the whites King so we is still defendant
yes we again we destroy the pawn
structure but really the idea is it's
reviving our our pawns the d4 pawn and
the the c5 pawn okay so who wants to
offer the best move for for black try to
think about is black so I'm going to
flip the board
sorry Queen d5 is an option yes okay
anybody else yeah
Queen c7 c7 is also an option that's
correct
so all those all those Queen moves we
favor all those Queen moves and that's
that's very natural because we want to
take out our queen out of the spin this
is one of our most annoying pins that we
have in this position so in the game
black chose this move Queen to d5
satellite in the Queen attacking f3 pawn
yeah so basically we will white as a
weakness now on f3 and d4 and it's very
natural for us to come there and take
the pawn now Queen c7 though will
probably not be the best chance for
black because white has this move here
well first of all what's our goal is why
we want to push d5 right we want to
mobilize those points but if I play d5
immediately that could just kept you on
c5 that's not so good so the best move
for white here would be
yeah very good queen to e3 again looking
at the defending the pawn on c5 but also
attacking the e7 pawn now it looks like
they can just play
b6 but that's not so good right
d5 excellent BAM
always move forward charge d5 and
obviously taking on d5 would probably
very dangerous in though if Queen takes
twice and right here Bishop f6 Bishop e7
may be immediately rocked a is d5 also
looks pretty good and the room d8 lots
and lots of options
okay so black continues correctly
Queen to d5 attacking our pollen f3 and
in this case well why doesn't really
have time to defend that pawn because if
you play here again Queen a4 well like
is gonna play is six and what have we
done doesn't make any sense so he took
on e3 hey I'm sorry
only 7 with the bishop Queen takes f3
okay well the problem for white now is
that this position is quite dangerous to
the king that exposed so let's think
together what would be the best move
here for white how would we proceed
cautiously
Queen III rocketry okay so we have
community rocketry okay well let's look
at those options so rook Italy first
obviously we are scared about Queen g4
check and what do we do now
now if root 2 G 3 which looks the most
logical move in a position this would
probably be bad because once we move our
rook away what a change in the position
the bishop is no longer defended so any
move any moving chess has its advantages
and disadvantages
I always tell to all of my students
every move even if you blunder the Queen
still has some advantage okay so how can
we use this what would be the response
for black yeah right so when we usually
get a puzzle we need to look at three
things first we call them action moves
oh oh some people call them act active
moves number one or checks
number two captures number three threats
so obviously our committee proves we can
take other of the rooks with a queen but
in this case we actually we can take on
d1 and then take on e7 offtake here but
usually the bishop and upon both less
than a queen so quaintly take some d4
that's a capture yes and if it takes us
I would take take take and that we're
going to hopefully draw here would white
obviously coupon down so the voltage
Utley it doesn't work King to h1 I see
here two ideas for black
perfect so again what a change in the
position the rook is lined up with a
queen so we can either try to play
Bishop h6 and get the material or we can
play even I wouldn't thought about the
roof takes e7 takes maybe some maybe
some perpetual check or hunt the King
down not sure what's the evaluation here
exactly but looks really dangerous
so unfortunately rook to e3 does not
work Queen III probably same things
might happen I would assume that Queen
g4 check Queen g3 this actually looks
pretty good for white if he is able if
white is able to exchange the Queen's
this is definitely going to be a
favorable endgame because I have no idea
how black is gonna stop me from pushing
my pawn so probably in this position
black needs to go back to d5 and just to
block it the pawn just to make sure that
we lucky the pond and I'm not sure that
white has a way here to make progress
because we're also pinned we'll also
have to worry about the weak King no way
for us to make progress
so hopefully this gave a good hint on
how we should play with white so again
we have two problems here in this
position number one is the king and
number two is the d5 square bingo very
good good job okay so basically we need
to defend those two squares Queen to g5
this is an interesting position because
those grandmasters who played in the
game black made a move now that actually
lost him the game so I'm going to flip
the board here and the position is not
not so simple actually for black because
the problem is that the d5 pawn is very
difficult to stop d5 d6 d7 very very
very difficult to stop this pawn so that
needs to make some decisions so think
about this at home and in here the chess
club
how would you continue here with black a
to d8
wow that's CA okay okay
like am I missing something yeah
positional sacrifice' now but okay rook
c8 is one of them h6 yeah nobody wants
to take a pawn nobody nobody's here is a
pawn grabber yes sir let's discuss those
two options that you guys just gave rook
c8 and H is h6 both are very good
because Roxy I like the rook a c8 your
you're involving your game in your
involving your rook into the game but
actually if you think about the ro
conceit is not going to do much I still
will be able to play maybe d5 or d6
moves like that although although -
technically there is a nice there is a
nice tactic here so rook c8 and if you
play if Y plays d5
Black has an interesting idea here
taking on these seven I always look at
those captures white can't take with it
with a rope obviously because Queen
takes on d1 and if it takes with a queen
then queen g4 and it's probably at least
a draw I mean the king king escaping to
itõs just looks too dangerous so d5
doesn't work but here's the here's the
interesting part
the other mode that you guys suggested
this h6 and I like both of those moves
because those moves are trying to move
the Queen away from g5 and because
remember our goal was with a queen to
defend g4 and to defend e5 the problem
is is that the Queen can move to g2
that's correct
yes and if we obviously if we again if
we exchange Queens in this position
black is almost helpless well here's a
helpless because we just cannot prevent
t5d 67 too much for us so on Roxy 8
would it will be the same of rook c8
Queen g2 and then if you don't exchange
Queens I can either play d5 or I can
take on b7 so it is not rook c8 and not
h6 now in the game the grandma hassle
actually took the pollinator BAM I gotta
say this is a very brave decision that
was made by black but obviously white
continued with his plan now d5
so defy was played so how do we know how
can black stop the pawns it's again
almost impossible in the game black
played Queen to a4 trying to bring his
Queen backwards d6 Queen d7 okay so
looks like he blocking it up pawns but
the problem is is that sometimes when
you blockade the opponent's pawns
it does matter well at which point on
the board you actually stop them because
right now it just it just looks like
they have too much too much pass forward
so what to move what would you guys do
here with white how do we continue it
still looks like we don't have much to
do here 25 ok what's the idea okay so
let's say if you play Queen d5 a play
rook a to C 866 would be so c6 after 25
or now of 25 but I can take with a rock
since this will be good if we somehow
force blood to take with the Queen but
if I take with a pawn or with the rock
that's probably not going to work so
well for us
oh I said CH it's okay
yeah so the idea of rook c8 is you know
I'm just trying to pick up on this yeah
this this backwards pawn on c5 so how do
we improve our position over here maybe
we can try to find a weakness
it's hard to say which pieces are worst
piece in this position it just looks
like everyone is in the right squares on
the right spots you can always go crazy
yeah h4 it looks like a that's an
interesting idea I would say that well
first of all I would be a little bit
concerned maybe you can just play h6 oh5
himself okay you know what I'm going to
use my advantage I have a passer on a6
you use you use h1 I use a pond so let's
say so H 5 H 5 I'm going to play a four
take okay I take of the H point
you better make me in three moves you
better do it in you better do it in
three moves the problem is is that the
so okay so which work so this guy
this this square is defended so I guess
we need to try to do it with this rook
here
oh and now and you work a four but even
if I don't do it okay for I probably
just put play a two right and what does
the Queen gonna go good idea good idea
in the game wipe wipe late something
very kind of similar he used what we
call the elevator and the elevator is
when we move a rock up and we slide it
to the side it's like you know put it
the floor and so it only it's the
question is which floor do we need to
choose and which rook both of our rooks
is same pretty good to be honest and you
know the previous step pretty equal but
where would you put the rook I mean
probably not on the H file because again
the H pawn is not going to be attacked
so much yes F file because again as you
guys mentioned before
again this f7 pawn might become the
weakness so white played rock to d3 so
Rudy T was playing the game
a5 and rook f3
now the question is let's say just black
plays a for what would happen then Queen
a for yeah maybe you can play careful
but then I can maybe play a five yes
always a member the number one candidate
moves you always have to look for action
moves first always actually moves checks
captures and threats no checks
so rook takes of seven is actually a
threat because if he takes one of seven
Queen to d5 yeah name made next movie so
in this position black after white
played the roof to f3 black realizes
uh-oh he's gonna make me so he played
Queen to c6 in this case well he's also
attacking the rook so why played rook e
2 e 3 this is a good nice nice idea to
defending the the rope but also just
making sure that this pawn won't keep
rolling down down this path so route e 2
e 3 a 4 and now rook to D 3 again what
has changed put in the position every
move is an advantage in a disadvantage
so the Queen moved from d7 to c6 so d7
because became an I guess
unblocking it I'm dock area
well black had to move because otherwise
white plays d7 and white to move yeah
exactly what exercise it's the same
thing although we don't have a mate but
even if the if the King takes we can
still check and check
that is it so root xf7 black did nothing
the rope he played 83 well some hope it
lately sound maybe just just two more
two more moves but it's correct very
good sharp right is Queen d5 nice
probably not not the minute the main it
is not to take a to under control but to
make some discovered attacks actually
making one move right Roca fate it would
be a nice move if a to King h8 okay why
to move the hardest part is to win a
winning position having against we
didn't lose they slipped away right so
close as to moves to moves like a 281 we
gotta be careful I have to make sure
that we find the winner
Queen a - okay so he blockades our
points you block it look at his bones I
think we need two would probably be
possible but again yeah yeah I want to
look for for those far mean look at our
pieces hovering there next to the King
smelling something I'm smelling some
blood
Quinn Italy it probably has Queen g4
maybe chicken
Queen then Queen d1 o Queen e2 saw some
contour play for black yes correct
so we first of all I would look at the
rota is g7 but that doesn't work and now
we see that something is something is
wrong here I mean we usually don't want
to put our queens in front of the rooks
and in this in this case that's what
happens so the black Queen is in front
of the rook Bishop to f6 was played
queen g4 check but now we have this nice
again this rook left
walks as a shield to the king so Rho 2 G
3 the Queen went back to e6 but here why
just took on g7 check King went to G a
Tony don't spot and I'm gonna give you a
chance to find the last move in the game
yes action moves comes first always look
at checks first this is our first
candidate move this is the only check
rook f8 check because and the black
assign because if I take obviously if I
take the rook Queen takes c6 check and
if I take on g7 I can probably just take
the Queen again and now rook takes eight
so in this position white one became now
we didn't we're not finished yet not
finished well let's figure out so as we
said black made this huge mistake in
this game he grabbed a he became greedy
to connect it so we also looked at rook
c8 and looked at h6 so those pawns those
moves will not help us so what will save
us there are two interesting moves in
this position and let's see let's see
who tries to to find this so one of the
moves is is split is pretty similar to
f6 so the other movies is f5 so there
are two options here so the number one K
it moves obviously we're going to look
for those checks again but we cannot
find anything but the other way is
actually to take on e7 so this is a
pretty interesting idea as well so take
again it can take with a quick with it
with a rock
because the Queen is going to take on d1
if the Queen takes on e7 then Queen to
g4 so this is one of those positions
where we are using this the symbol then
clear one so if you go here you have
this unclear list
kind of like a laying eight so I'm clear
clicking of one and Queen h3 check King
e2 and maybe even even then I can
probably take on a three so this is
quite a quite unclear the other way for
black to play is to play f5
so f5 again that actually the main idea
of this movie f5 is to bring the King to
to f7 so queen of five was played it was
not played but this was what was
supposed to happen now so what's the
idea so the idea is that what again can
athlete defy because I can take on his
seven now so the whites best chances
here is to play Queen III again we need
to try to exchange the Queen somehow so
Queen III Queen to d5 we'll want to make
sure that we keep the Queen's on the
board if we're playing as a black Queen
d5 Queen f4 and now the key move is King
to f7 that is pretty unusual nothing
unusual exchange but very unusual to
bring in there the king into the action
so so really in the game king of seven
rugby one can be played by white so
again this those variations are just
speculations to what could have happened
in the game and rook takes a seven roof
takes is seven King takes a 727 check
King f8 rook takes b7 Bishop takes d4 so
there is no checkmate
but there is Queenie 7 King g8 Queen h7
King f8 Queen e7 King g8 so there is no
made for white because luckily for for
for black is defending both of those
squares on G 8 h8 and also g7 f7 but
White has this very strong move here
rook to d7 but again it's not so little
for for black because black can just
move his his Queen to c4 and technically
this position is supposed to end in a
draw so that's pretty much it so as you
can see just to wrap up this this game
as you can see was all about this move
and here is where we had this unusual
exchange Bishop to f3 very very unusual
but if you think about it
really why doesn't have any other option
because if you give time for black time
works against white because if black
will would have activated his rook and
again put some pressure and he took out
the oh he would eliminate this pin this
would be you know pretty devastating for
white it's gonna be just much painful
for you to play
so Bishop FD take take and then again
activating your Queen Queen g5 was was
very good idea so d5 d6 and again
unfortunately black lost the game
because he took this pawn lately but he
could have had some chances after rook
takes is 7 or this move f5
not sure what it was exactly the
difference between f5 and and f6 but my
opinion is that if we try to play f6 as
you somebody suggested here the audience
just maybe because again we are blocking
this this Bishop and might be some
consequences to do that so that's kind
of point okay guys I hope you enjoyed
our lesson today and usual exchanges
thank you so much for joining us and
keep watching our YouTube channel thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]